ja also wir haben ja jetzt ein ganz
großes klimaprojekt angeblich von Herrn
Habig überall sollen jetzt die Gas und
Ölheizungen raus und die neue
Zukunftstechnologie ist die Wärmepumpe
wenn man mit irgendeinem Experten der
sich ein bisschen den Bereich auskennt
redet dann erfährt man überall das
Gleiche
wärmepumpen sind sicher eine sinnvolle
Technologie für moderne
Niedrigenergiehäuser überhaupt keine
Frage für alte
ältere weniger gedämmte Gebäude mit
älteren Heizungsanlagen sind Wärmepumpen
einfach völlig ineffizient man kriegt
das Haus nicht warm die Energiekosten
explodieren das heißt man muss nicht nur
die teure Wärmepumpe einbauen man muss
eigentlich sein ganzes Haus umbauen man
muss dämmen man muss die Heizung umbauen
und da sind reden wir über Kosten in die
Richtung von mehreren 100.000 €, ganz
schnell und die haben nur mal die
wenigsten Bürger im sparstrom und da
finde ich ist die Regierung auch einfach
unehrlich sie behauptet ja niemand wird
sein Haus verlieren niemand wird nicht
mehr heizen können aber dann kommt Herr
Lauterbach um die Ecke und sagt na ja
aber wir müssen Ausnahmen machen nämlich
Ausnahmen für Pflegeheime und
Krankenhäuser damit die nicht in ihrer
Existenz bedroht werden müssen muss es
so sein dass bei Pflegeheim und
Krankenhäusern also dass die nicht ihre
Gas- und Ölheizung verschrotten müssen
weil sonst wären sie in ihrer Existenz
bedroht nun Stimme mich ja hier
ausnahmsweise Lauterbach in dem Sinne zu
dass ich auch nicht will dass
Krankenhäuser und Pflegeheim in der
Existenz bedroht werden aber normale
Familien oder
ältere Rentner die jetzt gerade ihren
Ruhestand in ihrem abbezahlten Häuschen
genießen wollen die sollte man bitte
schön auch nicht in ihre Existenz
bedrohen ein völlig undurchdachtes
Projekt und vor allem der Clou ist es
bringt auch dem Klima nichts weil womit
werden die Wärmepumpen betrieben sie
werden mit Strom betrieben woher kommt
der Strom in Deutschland im Winter oft
zu über 80% aus fossilen Energieträgern
weil Solarstrom gibt's im Winter kaum
und wenn der Wind nicht bläst dann haben
wir eben vor allem wir haben die
Gaskraftwerke und wir haben die
Kohlekraftwerke das heißt die angeblich
sauberen wär werden mit fossilem Strom
betrieben und man hat das ja sogar
akzeptiert dass man dafür mehr Strom
braucht deswegen hat Habeck mehr
Gaskraftwerke schon genehmigt und um
diese Gaskraftwerke dann mit Gas
beliefern zu können bauen wir also jetzt
bis zu 12
lng-terminals in die Ost- und in die
Nordsee
lng-terminals wo der grüne Minister eine
Sondererlaubnis erteilt hat dass die
tonnenweise Chlor und andere giftige
Abwässer in die Nordsee und in die
Ostsee entsorgen dürfen das ist also
grüne Politik das soll eine Politik sein
die unser Umwelt erhält und noch ein
Beispiel für völlig inkonsistente
Maßnahmen habe ich will ja auch Solar
Energie ausbauen was ja erstmal
erfreulich ist aber da frage ich mich
wieso quält man Hausbesitzer mit einem
riesigen bürokratischen Aufwand wenn die
auf ihr Dach eine Solaranlage setzen
wollen wieso macht man das besonders
unattraktiv weil wenn der Strom dann ins
Netz gekriegt man wenig Geld wenn man
den Strom vom Netz braucht muss man viel
Geld bezahlen in anderen Ländern ist das
völlig anders da sind so nahpaneele auf
dem Dach so dass der Stromzähler
rückwärts läuft also attraktiv nein habe
ich will die Hälfte der Solarpaneele auf
Freiflächen setzen also auf Wiesen auf
Äcker was heißt den Landwirten den
Bauern wird das Leben noch schwerer
gemacht weil die Bodenpreise hochgezogen
werden wie Flora und Fauna und die die
Tiere dort darauf reagieren weil es
sowieso gar keiner wenn alles also jetzt
zugepflastert wird mit metallischen
Solarpanelen und das soll so grüne
Politik sein also alles das sind
Maßnahmen die nicht zusammenpassen das
ist ökoaktivismus völlig blind völlig
undurchdacht und ich finde so eine
Politik können wir uns nicht leisten ich
will auch dass wir unsere natürlichen
Lebensgrundlagen halten ich will auch
dass wir in Zukunft anders heizen auch
unseren Strom anders erzeugen aber bitte
schön dafür brauchen wir innovative
Technologien dafür brauchen wir Ideen
aber nicht solchen Irrsinn wie ein habe
ich betreibt der ist ruinös für
Millionen Menschen und er bringt weder
dem Klima noch dem noch der Umwelt
irgendeinen gewinnen das wäre außerdem
Technologie denn eine Idee von ihm
ja also zum Beispiel beim Heizen kann
man in anderen Ländern sehen dass zum
Beispiel Dänemark in Dänemark sind über
60 Prozent aller Wohnungen und Häuser
entfernen Wärme angeschlossen und diese
Fernwärme wird tatsächlich überwiegend
mit erneuerbaren Energien betrieben mit
Biomasse zum Beispiel oder in Kopenhagen
haben sie ein System dass sie die Wärme
aus den Abwassern nutzen und damit diese
Heizung betreiben also es gibt schon
innovative Ideen wie man sowas machen
kann dafür braucht man Investitionen das
ist etwas was man wirklich dann auch
ganzheitlich durchdenken muss aber das
wäre doch ein Plan und nicht dieser
Irrsinn die Leute sollen ihre Gas und
Ölheizung verschrotten und sollen was
einbauen was einfach nicht funktioniert
und wie gesagt mit den solarpanellen ich
finde das auch eine gute Idee dass die
wenn der wenn der Stromzähler rückwärts
läuft wenn einer seine Solaranlage wenn
er da reinspeist und wenn er dann Strom
braucht dann kann er ihn sozusagen zum
gleichen Preis deaktiv wieder haben
würde für die Leute das attraktiv machen
würden viele wahrscheinlich aufs Dach
draufsetzen und dann finde ich muss man
eben wirklich meine
Technologien die halt noch nicht da sind
Fusionsreaktor oder ähnliche Dinge die
werden ja erforsch gibt Unternehmen die
daran arbeiten aber da ist ja immer
wieder so das ist langfristig privates
Kapital ist sehr zurückhaltend solche
langfristigen Dinge zu finanzieren weil
es ja unsicher ist also ist es sinnvoll
wenn der Staat das macht und das
unterstützt und das machen wir in
Deutschland viel zu wenig da ist die USA
tatsächlich besser in solchen Fragen
einmal ob Herr Bruder ihn vielleicht
heute Abend schon wieder zustimmen muss
oder nicht ja ich fürchte ja das tut mir
richtig weh aber es ist so aber mein
Bruder bin ich doch nicht zustimmen darf
nein nein außer ihrer Position zu Putin
würde ich in vielen Punkten mit ihnen
übereinstimmen dann das trennt uns
leider schauen Sie wir erklären Sie sich
oder wir klären sie mir das habe ich
seine Politik macht er hat doch zwei
hochqualifizierte Staatssekretärin
seiner Seite ein Reichen und die Gold
geübt und routiniert und alte Hasen in
der Promotion von alternativen Energien
wenn er davon nichts versteht dann kann
er die doch fragen wie kommt so etwas in
derselbe Frage wie sie sich stellen das
sind doch keine Leute also nichts gegen
Gemüsehändler die bis gestern auf dem
Wochenmarkt Gemüse angeboten haben das
sind alles gebildete Menschen und das
sind Menschen die auch Berater haben die
ganze Institute unterhalten von Sie
beraten werden wie kommt das dass sie
mir eine so unglaublichen
Treffsicherheit in so ein riesen
Fettnapf treten ich gebe Ihnen die benef
auf Dauer verstehen
gebildete Leute aber sie haben das
überall wo sie hinschauen erinnern Sie
sich noch an die Vorhersage von Frau
Merkel im Jahre 2020 wäre das eine
Million Elektroautos geben und heute
werden ähnlicher Vorhersagen gemacht ich
finde es auch unglaublich dass wir
vorher sagen natürlich
Illusion ist genauso verbreitet worden
die
Illusion verbreitet wurde dass die
Impfung gegen kurvig immun macht bevor
wir einfach nicht merke Frau Gaschke
will die ganze Zeit ja ich glaube man
muss der Fairness halber ich sehe es im
Wesentlichen ähnlich wie sie aber man
muss der fairnesheimer einmal sagen es
werden jetzt nicht Heizung die
funktionieren rausgerissen und Leute
dann aus dem aus dem ist Klang ein
bisschen so nicht also aus dem nichts
gezwungen als ich eine neue Heizung zu
kaufen sind noch ein paar sondern wenn
sie wenn sie kaputt gehen dann sozusagen
sollen sie ab 24 doch schnell passieren
bestimmte Zeit abgelaufen sind also wir
können ja immer noch laufen
also es ist schrecklich aber es ist
nicht ganz so schrecklich und die der
zweite Punkt ist glaube ich wirklich ähm
also wenn es nicht fand feste
ökonomische Interessen sind weil
irgendeine Lobby sich gerade mit einer
Sache so gut durchgesetzt hat dass das
jetzt alle haben müssen das ist der
Gedanke ich weiß ähm
dann ist es glaube ja es ist überhaupt
Ideologie
etwas glauben und sozusagen die die
christlichen Religionen sind hier völlig
offen auf dem Rücken jetzt gibt's den
Glauben
Sozialismus ist ja auch
immer war und insofern die Leute wollen
das sieht man ja gerade bei den Jungen
darauf kommen wir vielleicht noch also
sozusagen die Leute wollen an was
glauben und das was mich irritiert ist
wir sind ja eine pluralistische
Gesellschaft eben kein 5-jahresplan
eigentlich sondern Regierung kann
abgewählt werden es gibt andere
gesellschaftliche Kräfte es gibt die
Gewerkschaften es gibt die Unternehmen
selbst und auch da steht sozusagen jetzt
die Bekämpfung der der Klimakatastrophe
überall vor der Klammer vor allem
anderen also ich frage mich in der Tat
auch und ich ist eine offene Frage ich
weiß keine Antwort darauf wann ist das
passiert das ist Thema wichtig ist haben
wir seit ein paar Jahren ja gewusst aber
wann ist es passiert dass sozusagen
alles andere dem Untersatz und wir haben
heute den ganz gutes Beispiel genau
dafür mit der Unterordnung mitgebracht
und zwar von Herrn Hassbecker nee ich
will noch mal zu dem Thema diesen dieser
heizungs-orgiesen Heizung was sagen wir
sind nämlich direkt betroffen wir haben
am Stadtrand hier und bei Berlin haben
wir ein Studio ein turnstudio in dem
Bearbeiten das ist ein altes Haus
teilweise gedämmt teilweise nicht gut
gedämmt also wie so ein was ich immer
vergrößert hat ja wie so eine umgebaute
Scheune und so also ein cooles Objekt
und so und da ist jetzt die Heizung
kaputt unsere Gasheizung aktuell kaputt
so
Wärmepumpe kommt für dieses Haus wird
mit einer großen Grundfläche definitiv
nicht in Frage jetzt was sollen wir nun
machen ja wir wissen selber also wir
werden wahrscheinlich dann doch noch mal
eine neue Gasheizung einbauen müssen
auch dieses Jahr und das ist doch
Irrsinn man muss doch da
Übergangsfristen und das nicht mit mit
mit dem Kopf durch die Wand das kann
doch nicht gehen das kann nicht
funktionieren für viele Leute nicht und
für uns auch nicht
einbauen
ab nächstes Jahr dürften sie es nicht
mehr verboten und ich meine das ist ja
auch alles etwas heuchlerisch also wenn
Sie zum Beispiel Zugang zu fahren Wärme
haben die Fernwärme in Deutschland ist
überwiegen Fossil betrieben aber wenn
Sie Zugang zum Fernwärmenetz haben
könnten wir nicht nee aber ich meine nur
wenn dann dürften Sie das also würden
sie einfach sich eine Fernwärme
Anschluss kriegen oder ist alles okay
aber da sieht und dafür können sie ja
nichts keinen Zugang haben dürfen sie
das nicht haben was haben sie an
technologischen Möglichkeiten ich meine
wir haben das auch bei uns im Haus wir
haben sogar mal geprüft mit der
Wärmepumpe noch vor Jahren weil wir
irgendwie dachten naja gut vielleicht
geht das ja zwei Gutachter beide haben
uns gesagt um Gottes Willen lassen Sie
die Hände davon sie müssen ihr ganzes
Haus umbauen sonst heizt das Ding nicht
sie haben nur explodierende Stromkosten
so und ab nächstes Jahr alle die in die
Situation kommen Heizung alt Heizung
kaputt was sollen die denn machen also
ich finde das wirklich so
unverantwortlich und dann sich
hinzustellen zu sagen das bedroht doch
niemanden ich meine das sind solche
irrenkosten wie sollen die Leute das
bezahlen also das ist ja wirklich nicht
nur der Einbau der Heizung Politiker die
wissen das doch es ist nicht dass sie
von ihren eigenen Plänen sich selbst
haben überraschen können die wissen doch
was es bedeutet
Blase wo sie das offenbar nicht
interessiert oder wo
Politik
ein Politiker kann im Notfall auch ein
Kredit aufnehmen der kriegt immer ein
Gerät und kann sich sein Haus umbauen
lassen und dann hat ein schönes niedrig
Energiehaus und dann kann er auch eine
Wärmepumpe drin haben aber was macht in
Rentnerehepaar die haben das Häuschen
endlich abbezahlt diese frohe die
wollten ihren Ruhestand genießen die
kriegen nirgendwo einen Kredit also
selbst wenn Sie Ihr Haus super dämmen
wollten weil sie sagen na gut vielleicht
rentiert sich irgendwann bei den Enkeln
die können das gar nicht also das ist
einfach nicht nicht von vorn bis hinten
durchdacht und dann kommt noch was dazu
ich meine das wird den Leuten ja auch
nicht gesagt die EU erweckt zurzeit
dieses Kältemittel zu verbieten was in
den Wärmepumpen ist das heißt
klimaschädlich ist also im schlimmsten
Fall zwingen wir jetzt Leute oder
animieren sie dieses Jahr sind sie noch
nicht gezwungen aber animieren sie jetzt
eine werbepumpe einzubauen im Haus also
die kann man ja draußen oder drinnen
aber wenn man sie drin einbaut dann ist
auf jeden Fall einfach Kältemittel drin
was möglicherweise in wenigen Jahren von
der EU verboten wird dann müssen Sie die
wieder rausreißen müssen die anderen
eine andere draußen einbauen damit die
mit einem anderen Kältemittel
funktioniert
80 das muss ich sagen das ist schon fast
schon zynisch ja nach dem Motto die
haben eh nicht mehr so lange
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
wild kämpft für Sie